I've heard it called a death letter but
I don't know if that is the actual name
I don't know if it has an actual name
but I do know what it is is something
that soldiers sometimes write when they
deploy in the harm's way then they put
it with your gear or in a footlocker
where it will be found or they give it
to a friend to pass on in case they die
a letter to the family
they won't see again the mothers that
gave them life to father's that raised
them to wives that they left at home to
children they miss and in some cases to
the children they've never even met
it's a goodbye letter with a title
something like in case I don't come home
well Jesse Givens rocked Springfield
Missouri wrote one of those letters he
wrote it to his wife Melissa and their
son Dakota nicknamed toad and to their
unborn son nicknamed bean who would
ultimately be named Carson and here is
what he said in that letter in case he
didn't come home my family I never
thought I would be writing a letter like
this I really don't know where to start
I've been getting bad feelings though
and well if you're reading this I am
forever in debt to you Dakota and the
bean I searched all my life for a dream
and I found it in you I would like to
think that I made a positive difference
in your lives I will never be able to
make up for the bad I am so sorry the
happiest moments in my life all deal
with my little family I will always have
with me the small moments we all shared
the moments when you quit taking life
seriously and smiled the cylons of a
beautiful boys laughter or the simple
nudge of a baby unborn you will never
know how complete you have made me each
and every one of you you saved me from
loneliness and taught me how to think
beyond myself you taught me how to live
and to love you open my eyes to a world
I never dreamed existed I am proud of
you stay on the path you choose never
lose sight of what is important you and
our babies Dakota you are more son than
I could ever ask for I can only hope I
was half the dad I used to be your Danny
but no matter what it makes me proud
that you chose me you taught me how to
care until it hurts you taught me how to
smile again you taught me that life
isn't so serious and sometimes you have
to play you have a big beautiful heart
through life you need to keep it open
and follow it never be afraid to be
yourself I will always be there in our
Park when you dream so we can still play
I hope someday you will have a son like
mine make them smile and shine just like
you
I love you code and I hope someday you
will understand why I didn't come home
please be proud of me please don't stop
loving life take in every breath like
it's your first I love you code I will
always be there with you I'll be in the
Sun shadows dreams and joys of your life
baby beam I never got to see you but I
know in my heart you are beautiful I
know you will be strong and big-hearted
just like your mom and brother I will
always have with me the feel of the soft
nudges on your mom's belly and the joy I
felt when we found out you're on your
way
I dream of you every night I always will
don't ever think that since I wasn't
around that I didn't love you you were
conceived of love and I came to this
terrible place for love I love you as I
do your mom and brother with all my
heart and soul please understand that I
had to be gone so that I could take care
of my family I love you being
I have never been so blessed as the day
I met Melissa you are my angel soulmate
wife lover and best friend I am sorry I
did not want to have to write this
letter there is so much more I need to
say so much more I need to share a
lifetime's worth I married you for a
million lifetimes that's how long I will
be with you please keep our baby safe
please find it in your heart to forgive
me for leaving you alone take care of
yourself believe in yourself you are
strong big-hearted woman teach our
babies to live life to its fullest and
tell yourself to do the same don't
forget to take toad to Disney World
I'll be there with you Melissa I will
always want you need you and love you in
my heart mind and soul do me a favor
after you tuck toad and beam in give
them hugs and kisses from me go outside
look at the stars and count them don't
forget to smile love always your husband
yes
and Jesse didn't come home on May 1st
2003 Jesse Gibbons was killed while
conducting combat operations in Havana
Iraq when his Abrams tank plunged into
the fray DS River after the bank along
the river collapsed the three other crew
members made it out of the tank Jesse
did not
another brave warrior gone like so many
other warriors he left behind a family a
wife and children and a mother and
father and friends and life he left
behind everything every smile every
laugh every hug from his boys every kiss
from his wife everything going
and on this Memorial Day let us remember
let us remember those soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines those brave warriors
who for us for our freedom left
everything behind and after the Sun sets
on this Memorial Day and darkness
consumes the sky go outside and look up
and say thank you to those heroes that
now grace the heavens and then look at
the Stars
and count them and as much as your soul
aches with sadness as you mourn your
fallen family and friends and brothers
in arms don't forget that they did not
sacrifice their lives for us to live in
that Ness
no they sacrificed their lives so we
could live in joy and happiness so even
on this most solemn day
Memorial Day don't forget for them
to smile